okay we're here with the president we're
very excited to be here I'm very excited
to be very grateful thank you very much
you must be a little wistful you must
feel a little like David Ortiz about a
month ago where you know you're you're
going on to great things in the next
chapter of your life sitting and you're
still heading but my feet hurt but but
you know you'll never quite have a job
as exhilarating well you know it it is
time you know I tell people that this
has been a great run I have loved this
job I'm not going to pretend that there
haven't been moments of great
frustration but it is a singular
privilege I think I'm as good a
president now as I've ever been because
you learn stuff eight years you've sort
of been around the track a bunch of
times but I also see now the wisdom of
the founders that at a certain point you
have to let go for the democracy to work
sure that there has to be fresh legs
there have to be new people and you have
to have the humility to recognize that
you know you're a citizen and and you go
back to being a citizen after after this
offices is over so we're just trying to
run through the tape and the great thing
is I've got an unbelievable team around
me of people who have done extraordinary
work I'm sort of the frontman for it
well that's very modest well you know
the fact that you that the team won't be
there in the same way I think is the
only thing that where you have a little
bit of regret so we're a week out from
the election yeah and I you're a history
buff
I think if when we look back if mr.
Trump is defeated I'm hopeful that we
will be the take away will be that
socialism was not such a dirty word
anymore because of our friend Bernie
Sanders and I'm just wondering why
someone who
was accused of being a socialist before
what do you think about the idea that in
America yes were capitalists but some
things just should not be for the profit
motive health care prisons the military
elections and I would add newsgathering
people say get the money out of politics
I think you got to get out of the news
business first or we're never gonna
learn anything well a couple things I
say first of all you know if you look at
the United States Canada Europe all the
advanced democracies then clearly you've
got to have a market-based system
because it's really productive and it
spurs on innovation and freedom and
entrepreneurship and you're gonna have
to have a social welfare state and you
know in some ways the label socialism
doesn't make that much sense in a
context where there's no economy that
doesn't have some socialist elements
meaning that there's some common goods
that we all agree everybody should have
mm-hmm that's what Social Security is
that's what Medicare is to some extent
that's what public schools are we all
chip in to make sure that everybody no
matter the circumstances your birth have
these baseline goods and as you know I
felt pretty strongly that health care
should be one of those one of those
goods I've also said in the past that if
I were designing a system from scratch I
would have probably looked at a
single-payer system but we do have
legacy systems and and that's the only
thing that sometimes when I've had
conversations with Bernie I've said to
him yeah we don't start from scratch
there there you've got a one trillion
dollar health care industry for example
and you got a lot of people who are
working for it and a lot of special
interests involved and so my goal in the
Affordable Care Act was if I can get
millions of more people insurance then
that's my first goal because for them
this is not an abstraction it's like I'm
not gonna lose my home or my kids gonna
get
and that's what we've done but I see it
as a starter home and then the question
is how do we make sure everybody
ultimately gets it because there's still
gaps in coverage I think the same is
true you know when it comes to some
other issues to me I think there is a
pretty bright line around prisons I
agree with you that the criminal justice
system should not be infected by the
profit motive this is the awesome power
of the state saying we can take
somebody's freedom away we can lock them
up because they've breached some part of
the social contract the the notion that
you want in you might incentivize people
to lock more people in or keep them
there longer or not provide the kind of
rehabilitation services so that they can
get out of there I think that's a
problem and so I'm very proud of some of
the work that we've been trying to do
along these lines
we got more work to do when it comes to
the media that you know that's a tougher
call because look state-run media that's
what they got in and well not state-run
but just like it used to be where it was
a lost leader for that for the network's
they didn't have to make a profit
because they had a monopoly though to
some degree right right so they were fat
and happy in this kind of environment
it's hard to figure out how you would do
that but you know the I think the
question I'd have when it comes to the
media is how do we create a space where
truth gets eyeballs entertaining and we
can build a common conversation what is
true when I leave here one of the things
I'm most concerned about is the
balkanization of the media where you've
got eight hundred stations you've got
all these websites people have
difficulty now just sorting out what's
true and what's not
yeah and if you don't have some common
baseline effects yeah you we can have a
disagreement about how to deal with
climate change but
if we have a big chunk of the country
that you share just discounts what 99%
of scientists say completely it's very
hard to figure out how we move the
democracy forward so I don't have a good
formula for that but I think that it's
something that I'll spend a lot of time
thinking about and seeing if maybe we
can build some platforms where everybody
says ok let's let's let's let's agree on
facts and then argue about means after
that ok let me ask you about a question
that I know people who watch our show
we're interested in which is marijuana
reform is that something that you care
about I do something I care about it's
now we both made jokes about it but it's
not funny to the people who get arrested
which is over half a million I think
last year you know you and I both could
have had our lives ruined not really by
smoking it but by being arrested for it
right and you know I feel like you had a
checklist about let's get rid of a lot
of the stupid stuff like opening up Cuba
you know you came out for gay marriage
I was hoping ending the drug war would
be on that list it's on the ballot now
in nine states in a week including
California for recreational and Arizona
and medical in places like North Dakota
isn't it time the federal government
caught up to progressive states like
Arizona and North Dakota well here's
what I'm I have always believed that to
the extent that the society legitimately
wants to guard against any kind of
substance abuse that you treated as a
public health problem look I'm an
ex-smoker
cigarette smoker x.x and really yeah I
read your Winker did you get something
in your eye there I thought I caught a
wink
I'm sure I'm a heck out of nicorette
really yeah but no what I when I passed
health care reform that was I think
right I'd had my last cigarette but but
the reason is because there was this
enormous public health effort to get
kids not to pick up smoking and to make
sure the parents felt guilty if if they
were passing on that that habit to their
kids and I and so that's where I think
we need to go with pot alcohol and so so
I don't think that legalization is a
panacea but I think that we're going to
have to have a more serious conversation
about how we are treating marijuana and
our drug laws generally the good news is
is that after this referenda to some
degree it's going to call the question
because if in fact it passed in all
these states you now have about a fifth
of the country that's operating under
one set of laws yeah and four-fifths in
another the Justice Department DEA FBI
for them to try to straddle and figure
out how they're supposed to enforce laws
in some places and not in others and
they're gonna guard against transport
transporting these drugs across state
lines but you know you've got the entire
Pacific corridor where where this is
this is legal that is not going to be
tenable now it's not something that I
think is gonna happen overnight and I
think there are some legitimate concerns
that people have about how you draw
lines on these issues but it is
indisputable that right now the biggest
drug crisis we have is with opioids many
of which are legal and are ravaging
entire communities all across the
country and
and for us to resore and not think of
everything through the criminal justice
lens but also through the public health
lens I think is something that's gonna
need to happen okay switching topics I
don't have anybody from my tribe of
atheists ever thank you for giving us a
shout out at your first inaugural but
you didn't mention non-believers I think
it was pardoned once more than one I am
it's not just in that speech I've done
it often well we appreciate it because
we do feel like Untouchables to a degree
I mean I don't know if you saw the
latest religion survey but almost a
quarter of the country are nuns I don't
mean the ones who hit me on the knuckles
with a ruler in Sunday school I mean
they put none for religion above right
right they're not no they're atheists
agnostics or they just don't want to get
up on Sunday right morning and we have
no representation in Congress if if our
numbers are represented to be over a
hundred Congress people right who felt
that way it just seems like we are not
included in the basket of diversity in
America which is odd because we are the
biggest minority that is a bigger
minority than any other minority you can
name oh don't you think we should get a
little more love you know I guess my
question would be whether there is
active persecution of atheists I think
that there are certain well I I think
for a candidate I I think you're right
that there are certain we might be my
patients probably most prominently
politics where there would be a bias
against somebody who's agnostic or
atheist in running for office I think
that's still true outside of that arena
though you seem to have done all right
with your TV show I am mad I don't I
don't get a sense the extent that
they're boycotting you it's because of
your other wacky ideas rather than your
particular view on religion what a
better idea the you know I usually agree
with you I I think I think the the
average American
if they go to the workplace somebody's
next to them but they're not poking
around trying to figure out what their
religious beliefs are so so so here's
what I would say that I think that we
should foster a culture in which
people's private religious beliefs
including atheists and agnostics our
respected and and and that's the kind of
culture that I think allows all of us
then to believe what we want that's
freedom of conscience that's what our
Constitution guarantees and you know
where we get into problems typically is
when our personal religious faith or the
community of faith that we participate
in tips into a sort of fundamentalist
extremism in which it's not enough for
us to believe what we believe but we
start feeling obligated to you know hit
you over the head because you don't
believe the same thing or to treat you
this as somebody who's who's less than
than I am but we might be more
pro-science in America if we were less
religious don't you think well you know
I think the the issues we have with
science these days are not restricted to
to what's happening with respect to
religion I there are a lot of very
religious scientists around I think the
problem is is that in our school systems
and to some degree and this is where it
is relevant with school boards around
the country that are mandating
curriculums and textbooks you start
seeing this weird watering down of
scientific fact so that our our kids are
growing up in an environment and this
connects with a to what I was saying
earlier about the media where
everything's contested that that nothing
is true because if it's on Facebook it
all looks the same
and if you're reading something from a
Nobel prize-winning physicist next to
some guy in his underwear and writing in
his basement yeah or his mom's basement
in on text it looks like it's equally
plausible and and part of what we have
to do a better job of if our democracy
is a function in a complicated diverse
society like this is to teach our kids
enough critical thinking to be able to
sort out what is true and what is false
what is contestable and and what is
incontestable and and we seem to have
have trouble with that and and our our
political system doesn't help okay I
want to ask you this question again it's
an issue I think you don't get asked a
lot about but it's important to my
audience I know people will roll their
eyes and say it's so California to ask
this but food purity yeah something that
means a lot to me somehow it got to be
elitist or liberal I don't get that to
want food that isn't full of pesticides
of food that wasn't created by torturing
animals that in factory farms isn't full
of antibiotics which is a problem in
itself I feel like we're upside down on
food we eat too much corn because we
grow too much corn because we subsidize
too much corn and you know one of the
problems with the Affordable Care Act is
that people were found to sicker right
then expected and that's partly birth of
the food I think and obesity and all the
work that Michelle's been doing yeah
yeah shouldn't be food would be put more
at the top of the agenda when when we
come to addressing health care there's
no doubt about it that right now we got
a disease care system we should have a
health care system and health care
system would include nutrition exercise
but also pushing back on corporal and
and and so yeah I think what is true is
that for a long time
agribusiness has a day
obviously my prominent seat at the table
in Congress it's bipartisan some of the
reforms that we've tried to initiate for
example on the school lunch program have
actually made some progress on this
front and Michelle deserves a lot of
credit for it as do a bunch of
organizations that have worked on this
you know the the I think the strategy
has to be one of persuasion and it has
to be more demand driven in the sense
that one of the things Michelle's
finding is is that when she worked with
Walmart or craft or what have you and
she said look here's the data this is
what parents want the profit motive can
actually work in favor of food purity as
long as there's good information out
there and so part of our strategy has
been how do we make sure that consumers
are where they've got the information
they need now I will tell you and this
may be controversial and some of your
audience it is important to look at the
science on this stuff so when it comes
to antibiotics for example the science
is clear we pump our animals full of it
and and that's not just a problem in
terms of what we're in ingesting it's
also a problem that more and more you
know bacteria is becoming resistant to
antibiotics but in some cases like for
example the GMO debate there are there
are areas where there are legitimate
concerns there are some areas where the
science seems to indicate well this is
okay we got back to the science it says
it doesn't increase the yield well exact
hadn't they used just as many if not
more pesticide well that's so so my
point is were that what we have to be
make sure we're doing whether we're on
the left or the right is being driven by
the science and if it turns out that
some of these genetically modified foods
aren't
healthier aren't more productive and use
more pesticides then we should follow
the science if in some cases they're not
causing any harm
then we should follow the science there
as well and that's what what what I've
tried to do in this administration is
and then this goes beyond just you know
nutrition policy what I always say to my
teams are figure out what is right as
far as as best we can tell figure out
what the best policy is figure out what
the science tells us figure out what the
facts tell us what are what are our best
ideas out there and sort through them
and then once you figure that out then
we'll worry about the politics after
that don't start with the politics and
then try to get the facts to fit into
the politics and I think that if you
know at minimum what that does is it
keeps us tethered to reality
it makes us go to bed at night feeling
pretty good about us you know what we've
been trying to do because we're not
constantly trying to tack to whatever is
fashionable or what public opinions are
out there we just try to figure out as
best we can what is the right answer and
I think all of that you think we ask too
little of the public politicians you
know of course we're always kissing up
to the public and saying things like if
we only had a government as good as the
people but the people aren't very well
informed they don't exercise the right
to vote and when they do they don't know
much about it I just feel like we don't
we don't ask the people very much we're
afraid to ask that people eat better you
know that the phrase was yes we can I
feel like they're not pulling their
weight on the we it's a partnership with
gonna eat better vote more learn
something you know I I actually think
that part of the pitch I've made
throughout my campaign and throughout my
presidency is exactly that that change
doesn't come from on high that if you're
waiting for Congress then you're gonna
be waiting a long time even a pretty
capable well-meaning president is going
to
only be able to take the country so far
without people ordinary folks all across
the country being engaged being involved
being active yeah I constantly quote
Louis Brandeis who said the most
important office in a democracy is the
office of citizen it's not president
it's not senator it's not mayor and so I
have tried consistently to say to the
American people that this is only going
to work if you're engaged now I will
tell you having traveled every state met
with people from every walk of life
people are basically good I you know I I
am a I'm a glass-half-full guy and an
optimist about the human spirit you are
right though that people are busy
they're stressed and they don't have
time to follow the intricacies of some
debate around Medicaid or you know
what's going on in Syria and so part of
that what when I say I want a government
as good as the the American people what
I mean by that is is that I think
people's instincts their gut what they
what they want out of life and how they
want to see people treated is actually
pretty good but the question then
becomes how do we get enough information
in front of them to be able to make good
decisions I've always believed that if I
could get into you know if I could sit
in the living room with every person in
America over you know that I've got the
majority on my side and a healthy
majority on my side on every issue that
we work on just by having a conversation
the problem is we got all these filters
and look if I watched Fox News I
wouldn't vote for me either right right
because you know you've got this screen
this funhouse mirror through which
people are receiving information how did
how to break through that is a big
challenge this whole conversation that's
been had lately
in in the aftermath of the rise of Trump
this notion that part of what's happened
is is that both Republican and
Democratic elites have neglected the
white working-class men truth of the
matter is is that every policy I've put
forward would make a huge difference
with the white working-class and the
black working class and the Latino
working class whether it's raising the
minimum wage or the affordable care act
given people health care who don't have
it and who are working hard and need
help or making sure that unions are
strong so that you could have a little
more leverage at the workplace or making
sure that you know something like the
consumer finance Protection Bureau is is
may is protecting against some scam
mortgage but what is true is that
because it's hard to get into the
details of all these issues with folks
who are running around dropping off
their kids at school and trying to punch
the clock and figuring out how to make
ends meet and just want to relax when
they come home and not watch you know
Meet the Press then in that environment
a lot of what people take in is just
symbols and signifiers and you get into
identity politics and cultural wars and
and and what I'd like to figure out and
I think Democrats do have an affirmative
obligation to do that do this is to work
harder to to to figure out in this new
age what's the equivalent of getting
into people's living rooms and being
able to have a conversation and being
able to listen to people and and and
I've been able to do this successfully
during my campaigns I have not always
been able to do it as successfully here
in this White House partly because this
bubble that's created around me does
American need to be an empire we have
more troops in more places than any
Empire in the history of
world we spend over 600 billion on
defense and that's not including the
nukes taking care of veterans homeland
security when you add it all up it's
probably over a trillion to keep the
monsters away I'm wondering if we could
be just as safe spending half as much
eisenhower warned when he was close to
the end of his second term like you were
now about the military-industrial
complex and it seems no president of
either party ever makes any progress on
that pushing back on that will it ever
happen did you want to do that well look
I keep in mind Billy when I came into
office we had 180,000 troops just in
Iraq and Afghanistan now we probably
have about 15,000 so that's pretty big
but we still spend a bunch of folks who
still spend morale you know actually you
know our spending I think has has been
steady here's what I'd say that humility
and foreign policy is is a useful trait
particularly in the Oval Office
I think bad things happen around the
world and our natural instinct is we
should do something there are times
where our intervention makes a
difference
but there are a lot of times where
unintended consequences can result in
more problems when we intervene and
sorting out where those
where those issues play out is I think
one of the biggest challenges so that
any president has my bias is that if it
comes to defending the American people
against Al Qaeda ISIL somebody who wants
to blow up a train station in midtown
Manhattan but I'm gonna go after them
and I make no apologies about it and I
want a vigorous military in place and
when it comes to maintaining a basic
international order so that a guy like
Kim jong-un in North Korea doesn't
suddenly start holding all of Asia
hostage because he is building a bunch
of nuclear weapons and and feels free to
threaten everybody else it's important
for us to have alliances in place and to
be able to work on the international
scene and us having the most powerful
military on earth helps that happen
it helps check the impulses of some
other bad folks and and I will tell you
as somebody who has now served as
commander in chief for the last eight
years not only are the men and women in
uniform that I work with extraordinary
you know you meet 23 year olds who are
in charge of life and death with
missions and maintaining billion-dollar
pieces of equipment and they just
execute and do it unbelievably well but
what you also discover is my top brass
Joint Chiefs of Staff they're not the
chickenhawks who are going around trying
to get us into every single war that you
know the the the generals the Colonels
the the commanders that I work with they
know the wages of war and they're
actually pretty thoughtful about it
and typically in the Situation Room
they're the ones who are like well
before we go half-cocked on something
let's really think about this because
this is what it would be involved and
they have seen what's what's involved
because most of them
our people who were fighting in Iraq and
fighting in Afghanistan and they know
how hard these environments are and that
no matter how good our intentions a lot
of times it can go haywire but having
said all that I think we should have
restraint I think we should have
humility I think we have to wherever
possible work multilaterally and not
just unilaterally because if we can't
organize coalition's to do things that
means that maybe we're we haven't
thought everything through having said
all that it turns out that as as flawed
is sometimes our foreign policy can be
or whatever blind spots we have we
really are the indispensable nation if
we if there is a you know typhoon that
wipes out someplace in Southeast Asia
our military is the only organization
that has the infrastructure to help
those folks quickly when a bola came out
we actually had to build the platform
whereby everybody else could even think
about bringing their doctors and nurses
in if you have a rogue nation that
decided it was going to you know take
action that significantly threatened a
lot of people I'd want to know that the
US military was there and so and and and
I can tell you sitting aside our
military power there's not an
international meeting I go to in which
if we weren't sitting at the table
nothing get done because for the most
part other countries don't have either
the capacity or the inclination and when
you've got a bunch of authoritarian
governments out there
and creeping authoritarian impulse
around the world we also are the ones
who are pushing back most effectively
imperfectly but most effectively against
locking up journalists and killing human
rights activists and making sure that
poor people get food and dealing with
public health crises I think if you see
the world from my seat
I won't a sort of a sort of that the one
thing I think is important for
progressives to guard against is a
tendency sometimes to not fully
appreciate that abet America the bad
guys that America is a pretty is not
just a great nation in the sense that
it's powerful but that our values and I
are and our ideals actually matter and
we do a lot of good around the world and
there's some things that we do that are
either ineffective or imperfect but
there's a lot to be proud of and there's
a lot to build on yeah now what we got
to do is make sure that we get our own
house in order so that we can key on
doing they know you're off to Ohio right
you've got an election to rigged and I
want you I want you to get out there
because boy it's it's a very nervous
time for a stately people who are
worried about mr. Trump that the stakes
are high
I I know we you know we're getting the
we're getting there we're getting the
Gong but but but but I will say this the
choice in this election should be really
clear and and and anybody who's watching
your show and was
mine was a supporter of Bernie's a
progressive generally this idea that
somehow well you know both of them have
problems and yeah nothing will change
either listen all the progress we've
made on climate change Paris agreement
HFC agreement Aviation Agreement the 20
million people who have health insurance
that right now that didn't have it
before all the progress that we've made
on trying to check the excesses Wall
Street and you know dodd-frank and the
and the consumer finance Protection
Bureau
any chance of immigration reform
including the work that we did to make
sure that these amazing dreamer kids all
across the country who are now going to
college or serving in our military are
not suddenly deported or at risk of
deportation every single issue that
we've made progress on over the last
eight years is gonna be on the ballot in
the form of this choice and I have
worked with Hillary Clinton I know her
and she is somebody who cares about
these issues she does her homework she
cares deeply about ordinary folks her
policies are aligned with yours and mine
and yes she is somebody who believes in
compromise and that you don't get a
hundred percent of what you want but you
know what that's the way this democracy
works anybody sitting on the sidelines
right now or deciding to engage in a
protest vote that's a vote for Trump and
that would be badly damaging for this
country and it would be damn damaging
for the world so yeah
no no complacency this to get out there
get out there thank you so much did a
hell of a job in this office I know I
speak for myself on my own loss means a
lot that you did this for me I wasn't on
the show that often I watched it all the
time really that's it well that's nice
to hear
Thank You mr. president preciate it all
right